[Musique]
mélanie poker nous a rejoint pour notre
rendez-vous junior de la semaine et on
va parler électro bonjour mes amis
bonjour camille de la musique électro
plus précisément parce qu'en fait la
ville de versailles
tout ne fait pas mais c'est le berceau
de la french touch un des groupes
français les plus célèbres et versailles
et air alors le week-end dernier il ya
eu le festival électro chic avec
plusieurs concerts mais il y a aussi des
ateliers dont celui de faire son propre
morceau de musique électro c'était la
médiathèque de vélizy et vous pouvez y
faire de la musique assistée par
ordinateur la n va aux lamas autre
succès pour la musique simplement le
fait de produire de la musique
via un outil numérique qu'en
l'occurrence un ordinateur et avec
derrière un logiciel on a une partie
mixage on va avoir tous les éléments qui
il choisit à
donc les instruments pour choisi on va
utiliser et ensuite une partie
séquençage on va dire pour tel
instrument tu vas jouer de telles notes
je vais jouer de tels rythmique mixage
séquence assez commença jeu rythmique ça
semble un peu compliqué quand même un
peu barbare qui peut suivre cet atelier
beaucoup de monde ça commence dès 10 ans
ça paraît compliqué ce qu'en fait ce
sont des mots qu'on n'utilise pas tous
les jours mais comme tout découverte
d'une activité il faut de la patience
alors dans cet atelier une partie qu'on
va appeler prise en main du logiciel
c'est presque le plus barbare mecque le
logiciel on choisit son instrument le
rythme qu'on veut lui donner qu'il soit
rapide lent faire des boucles et ensuite
on descend les éléments sur une timeline
je le disais ça peut se faire dès 10 ans
lors de ce premier atelier étaient une
dizaine à s'y être essayé mais ça
s'adresse aussi aux plus grands le voit
l'image s'appelle dylan lui l'a 20 ans
mais ça faisait longtemps qu'il voulait
composer ses propres morceaux écoutés
l'oeuf j'ai vraiment pris mon envie d'un
vrai et il sait c'est vraiment c'est
vraiment une expérience inoubliable une
expérience innovante une nouvelle
expérience pour moi et
ça me plaît de réaliser ça je voulais
faire une formation au dj mais j'avais
pas les bases
elle n'avait pas les bases mais là avec
avec cette expérience que je viens de
découvrir cet atelier bah je me dis
peut-être un symbole c'est un premier
début pour se voir être dj après pour
faire des mix it ou trois autres
ateliers sont prévus le mercredi et les
samedis suivants au labo numérique
devises
merci beaucoup mais l'allié donc tout
pour devenir peut-être les nouveaux
faits ni sur les nouveaux horaires on
l'espère en tout cas
les informations sont à retrouver sur le
site internet